when we went to University when we were
the age of a lot of the guys that are
seeking advice online at the moment
there was there was nothing online but I
don't think that there was a sense of
being lost despite the fact that there
was less information out there I don't
think that
and and that's not to say that me and
you tumbled into some like perfect slick
archetype of being of finding our place
within University or whatever I think
both of us in like like certain ways
we're a little bit disjointed and took
time to find our feet yeah I
what do you think's changed why is it
that guys are I think it's maybe the
comparison aspect of it because I
definitely didn't have a clue what I was
doing and I think
it was only until I was 23 yeah 23 when
I became a personal trainer and I was
like okay so this is probably a step in
the right direction before that I was
working as a manager in Hollister worked
the club club promoter for a bit doing
all sorts but I never felt lost I was
just like
okay well yeah I'll just I'll just do
this but I I had no one else to compare
myself to like I wasn't comparing myself
to any other 22 or 23 year old out there
in fact I thought I was doing pretty
good because I was like Hey I've come
out of University and I've got a job
whereas now you got people who were like
16.
20 21 22 who were just making a killing
and I think because they're so out there
on social media
and they have gained quite a lot of
following because of the success they've
had I think a lot of guys maybe that age
or even a little bit older they're like
hang on how's this guy managed to make
so much money and so successful and I am
literally
doing nothing with my life comparatively
even if you are on a graduate scheme at
Hollister
I think that's one thing and then maybe
the value of a degree is mostly gone
downhill now I don't think
people are thinking oh should I go to
university anymore is it worth it like
do I need to go do I don't need to go
like what should I spend my time
learning
I think it can be quite confusing out
there all of my richest friends don't
use their degrees Yeah I don't use my
degree you don't judge the guy that I
was at at his house before unbelievably
successful marketing business did
philosophy at Uni can't remember any of
it
like I I think that all of that's very
correct is a a quote that says
comparison is the thief of Joy yeah and
maybe that maybe that contributes to a
big part of it the fact that
just your ability to see
no point no no one percent success
absolute outliers crushing at a younger
age than you
uh so I went to the UFC's power slap
event in Vegas last Saturday which was
[__] wild and I saw Aiden Ross one of
the biggest streamers in the world I saw
all of the milk boys Kyle uh Mike from
uh impulsive hospital I was there done
Bilzerian was there like just bing bing
bing like tick pick your steeple do it
like everybody right all of the the
biggest guys that would have been around
that that sort of community
and you look I mean Aiden Ross I think
he's maybe 20 20 21 he's one of the
biggest streamers in the world
um like I show speed is something
similar maybe even younger maybe he's
19. uh
Kyle and all of the milk boys and maybe
getting toward the mid-20s mid late 20s
but they've got like businesses and
franchises and clothing companies and
all this stuff
I guess a lot of guys are just thinking
oh well maybe I need to take the
influencer route
and that's why they're so confused yeah
perhaps and what about is there
something else going on about some about
men's roles do you think like young guys
roles in in the world is something being
lost there
I guess so I mean I'm not massively
clear on what it was to begin with
what what it used to be young men's
roles I don't well this is the point
with me and you were uni I was also
useless I had no idea I didn't know what
I was supposed to do but it that didn't
feel like a pressure to know what I was
supposed to do so
every generation looks back at the
generation coming after them and can't
believe how quickly they're growing up
yeah I'm pretty glad I'm not a part of
this younger generation I feel like
we had a pretty sweet why
just felt like a simpler time growing up
first of all without social media I
think maybe when I get onto Facebook
that was probably when I'll
was at University just before University
email address when we went so it was
nice just to have my teen teenage years
without
all the social media we just weren't on
phones yeah
I had like a Sony Ericsson and Nokia
I just I feel like I spent a lot more
time being present
and then um
the world's a bit mad now
like really mad with all the woke stuff
and
I don't know well one of the problems
that you have is
everybody always presumes that giving
more freedom to people will allow them
to more accurately choose the precise
thing that they want right if you if
there's one pair of jeans in the store
and you go in then maybe you wanted a
different pair you want to get that one
if there's a thousand pairs of jeans in
the store fantastic you can optimize
your choice precisely for the exact type
of genes the cut the color the length
the stretch the whatever right where's
everything the problem is that takes the
decision of the outcome of success or
failure out of the hands of your limited
choices and more into your hands you
know you see how this would be an issue
right if you choose an ever so slightly
sub-optimal pair of jeans that's your
fault because there was an optimal pair
of jeans for you to take and I think
that the same thing happens here that if
the rules and guidelines
um that people previously would have
followed
have perhaps been removed a little bit
and if expectations have been raised you
should be doing more at this age you're
able to compare yourself so on and so
forth that's a really Perfect Blend of
um
internal uncertainty and external
pressure that can cause someone to think
holy [__] like I I don't know what I'm
supposed to do with my life I don't know
all of the things previously the traits
that I would have taken pride in the uh
you know the protector provider
competent courageous Brave stands up
well under pressure doesn't give up
easily emotionally mature all of those
things that specifically men would have
relied on
that's only one step away from toxic
masculinity yeah right all of those can
very easily be protecting why is it that
you think that women need to be
protected should not be the case that
women can be safe without the protection
of men what is it you're intending on
doing with them they'll provide it you
think that women can't afford to look
after themselves you want women back in
the kitchen do you don't want them to
have careers you're like holy [__] like
can we not turn the volume of this
conversation yeah because you must have
had a lot of these conversations with
the interviews you've done do you find
do you think it's uh the dating
Market at the moment is the worst it's
ever been
it's a really good question
um I certainly think that it's the most
confusing and the outcomes seem to have
the highest rates of sexlessness that
we've ever seen so 30 of men ish around
about a third of men haven't had sex in
the last year aged 18 to 30. this stat
that just came out from Pew a couple of
weeks ago
fifty percent of men say that they're
pursuing a relationship short-term or
long term which means that 50 of men
aren't aged 18 to 30. now both me and
you and everybody that's listening that
has a penis who's been through the ages
of 18 to 30 knows what the male sex
drive feels like at that age can you
imagine what it what the world has to be
like and what your experience of life
has to be like for your sex drive to be
chopped in half essentially right
driving mad yeah but but these guys are
self-identifying as saying I'm not
bothered about a short-term or a
long-term relationship like for you to
get yourself to the stage where you've
tamped down on that sex right and
there's a talk of like reducing levels
of testosterone phthalates in the water
increasing levels of estrogen and
everything that we eat less time outside
blah blah blah like people know that
testosterone's dropped one percent a
year since 1980.
um
so that may contribute to it too but in
2019 it was 61 of guys were short-term
and long term looking for the short-term
long-term mating thing and that's
dropped 11 in four years it's like rapid
decline so I certainly do think that
what are these guys doing and they just
focusing on their own
[__]
that's a really good question I don't
know I think that a lot of guys are
retreating from The Real World monk mode
now but if they were if it was proper
monk mode where it's I'm working on my
self-development I'm building myself up
I'm
that would indicate that they're taking
a break to then come back in to
integrate into both society and dating
but I think that a lot of these guys are
just fully checked out even at younger
ages you know like under 20 like guys
that are under 20 going men going their
own way it's like dude like you haven't
had chance to not go your own way
I'm trying to think if I was 18 year old
if I was 18 now
it would be a lot harder
compared to when I was 18
harder to do what
it was a date
I think now because of social media it's
obviously way more competitive and I
just think a lot of women who are let's
say I was 18 they're 18 they're probably
not going to be looking for an 18 year
old to date they'll be looking for older
guys to date but I feel like that wasn't
as much of a thing back then absolutely
not no but the the amount of people that
you had access to would have been
limited what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
face
[Music]
foreign